Os voy a hacer una pregunta: ¿Dónde creéis que hay más desigualdad económica?
¿En Silicon Valley… o en Burundi?
Exacto: la respuesta es Silicon Valley.
Pero vale, esto no tiene que ser una mala
noticia para la gente que vive en Silicon
Valley.
Por ejemplo, imagina que trabajas como ingeniero
de sistemas para las oficinas que tiene CISCO
en San José.
Fácilmente, puedes estar cobrando unos 7500
dólares al mes.
No está mal ¿Verdad?
Bueno, si te comparas con tu amigo, que trabaja
de ingeniero de software en Google, te vas
a sentir como un auténtico mendigo.
Una persona en esa posición puede estar cobrando
hasta 11.000 dólares al mes.
Y por supuesto, todo eso es una propina comparado
con lo que gana Elon Musk, Mark Zuckerberg
o cualquiera de los multimillonarios que viven
en esta zona.
Dicho de otra manera: cualquiera se sentiría
como un pobre si tuviera como vecino a las
mayores fortunas del planeta.
Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando… con un
sueldo de 150.000 dólares al año ¡Yo también
quiero sentirme pobre!
Y tenéis razón.
Pero no todo es tan bonito.
En una zona del mundo con tantísimo dinero
concentrado… ¿Qué creéis que ocurre?
Pues que los precios se ponen por las nubes.
Por ejemplo ¿Cuándo diríais que cuesta
un apartamento de 2 habitaciones en Mountain
View?
Por si no lo sabéis, Mountain View es la
ciudad donde Google tiene sus oficinas centrales.
Pero no penséis que es ninguna metrópoli.
Con poco más de 60.000 habitantes, tiene
más o menos la misma población que Ávila,
por poner una comparación.
Pues bien ¿Cuánto diríais que cuesta alquilar
un apartamento de 2 habitaciones?
500 dólares?
1000?
2000?
Pues atentos… después de haber buscado
por Internet, lo más barato que he encontrado
estaba por 3400 dólares.
Habéis oído bien. 3400 dólares.
Para que os hagáis una idea, las casas en
Silicon Valley son un 60% más caras que la
media de todo Estados Unidos.
Y ya sé lo que os estáis preguntando…
hombre, con un sueldo de 11000 dólares al
mes ¡No me importaría pagar 3500 dólares
de alquiler!
¿Verdad?
Y tenéis razón.
Pero… a ver ¿Por qué es famoso Silicon
Valley?
¡Exacto!
Por los emprendedores.
Es decir, el atractivo de Silicon Valley no
es ir a trabajar PARA Facebook sino ir a crear
tu propio Facebook.
Pero, pensadlo bien ¿Montaríais una empresa
en un sitio donde los precios son tan caros?
Probablemente no.
Y eso explica esta noticia.
La élite tecnológica de Silicon Valley está
abandonando Silicon Valley en manadas debido
a la mentalidad general y el precio de la
vivienda
¡Tal cual como lo oís!
Para que os hagáis una idea, en el año 2017,
Silicon Valley tuvo inmigración neta negativa
por primera vez en décadas.
Es decir, había más gente marchándose que
gente llegando.
Y esto es sorprendente si tenemos en cuenta
que esta zona del mundo ha crecido a ritmos
nachovidalianos desde los años 50.
Sin ir más lejos, en el año 1950, Mountain
View tenía unos 6000 habitantes.
En 2017, tenía más de 81.000.
Y lo mismo ha ocurrido con todas las demás
ciudades de esta zona.
Sin embargo, según una encuesta, la mitad
de los residentes asegura que está pensando
en marcharse debido a los costes de vida.
Y algunos ya lo han hecho.
Entre otros, este señor que veis aquí.
Peter Thiel deja Silicon Valley por Los Ángeles
Para quien no lo sepa, Peter Thiel es algo
así como el Santa Claus de Silicon Valley.
Junto a Elon Musk, es uno de los fundadores
de PayPal.
Después, se metió a inversor de riesgo y,
podríamos decir, que es uno de los padrinos
de Facebook.
Al menos, el primero que empezó a soltar
dinero cuando la empresa estaba todavía en
pañales.
Pero la pregunta es… ¿Por qué hay tanta
gente abandonando Silicon Valley?
¿De verdad el coste de vida es la principal
razón… o hay algo más?
Y lo que es más importante… ¿Es este el
fin de Silicon Valley tal y como lo conocemos?
Hoy vamos a responder a esta pregunta.
Pero antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
NO ES PAÍS PARA EMPRENDEDORES
En otro vídeo de VisualPolitik os contaba
cómo se financia una startup en Silicon Valley.
Las rondas de financiación, los fondos de
capital riesgo, etc… Efectivamente, Silicon
Valley es el mejor lugar del planeta para
encontrar a gente dispuesta a apostar por
tu idea.
Por otro lado, también es la Disneylandia
de la mano de obra cualificada.
Si quieres montar una empresa de coches automáticos,
necesitas contratar a gente que tenga formación
en las últimas tecnologías.
Si vives en Valladolid, España, te va a ser
prácticamente imposible encontrarlo.
Sin embargo, los mejores talentos del mundo
se reúnen en esta área del planeta listos
para hacer negocios o ser contratados.
¿El problema?
Que esos talentos a los que te gustaría contratar
están demasiado ocupados cobrando 150.000
dólares al año en Google.
Y por muy fantástica que sea tu startup,
es difícil competir con los sueldos y, sobretodo,
la estabilidad que puede ofrecer un gigante
como Google.
“¿Cómo se supone que vas a empezar una
startup en un garaje si el garaje cuesta millones
de dólares?” –Ajay Royan de Mithril Capital,
en declaraciones a The Economist
¡Pero aquí no termina la cosa!
¿Recordáis que California tiene los impuestos
más altos de todo Estados Unidos?
Pues la cosa no se queda aquí.
Veréis, en Estados Unidos, los estados no
sólo tienen autonomía para subir o bajar
sus propios impuestos.
También pueden elegir cómo quieren cobrarlos.
Por ejemplo, el Estado de Texas no tiene impuesto
sobre la renta.
Prácticamente todo lo que recauda, lo hace
a través de impuestos indirectos.
Es decir, impuestos que se ponen a los precios
de los bienes que compramos.
Pues bien, California es todo lo contrario.
A duras penas tiene impuestos indirectos.
Y casi toda la recaudación viene de los sueldos
de los trabajadores y, sobretodo, de las rentas
del capital.
En otras palabras, que si eres un inversor
y das beneficios altos un año, ya puedes
ir preparando la cartera.
El estado de California te va a cobrar mucho
más que cualquier otro.
Y esto no son buenas noticias si tenemos en
cuenta que Silicon Valley es lo que es, en
buena medida, por los inversores de capital
riesgo.
Sin embargo, esta no es la única razón.
Por ejemplo, Peter Thiel no se ha marchado
por los impuestos.
Si no, no se habría ido a Los Ángeles, que
también está en California.
Lo cierto es que, no son pocos quienes dicen
que Silicon Valley está perdiendo gran parte
de esa diversidad que, en su día, fue la
marca de la casa.
Peter Thiel: “Silicon Valley se ha compertido
en un estado de partido único”
Básicamente, Peter Thiel apoyó a Donald
Trump en la campaña.
Y, por lo visto, este tipo de cosas no se
ven muy bien en Silicon Valley.
Y lo cierto es que, en Silicon Valley, tienen
muchas razones para no tenerle mucho cariño
al Presidente del país.
Ahora mismo vamos a ver por qué.
H 1-B
¿Recordáis que os decía que los mayores
talentos de todo el mundo se concentran en
Silicon Valley?
Pues oísteis bien.
Dije el mundo.
El mundo entero.
No sólo Estados Unidos.
Eso significa que el 57% de la gente que trabaja
en las empresas tecnológicas del Valle sea
de origen extranjero.
Es decir, que hay más inmigrantes que estadounidenses.
¿Y cómo entran en el país tantos inmigrantes?
Pues muy sencillo: con la ya famosa visa H
1-B.
Básicamente, se trata de un visado que te
permite trabajar en Estados Unidos entre 3
y 6 años.
Para tenerlo, necesitas que te contrate una
empresa y que justifique que tu trabajo es
especializado.
Es decir, que realmente tienes unos conocimientos
que te hacen único y que necesitan contratarte.
Si te echan de esa empresa, tienes un mes
de plazo para encontrar otro trabajo.
Si no, te tienes que marchar.
Por supuesto, esta visa la tiene que solicitar
la empresa que te contrata.
Y el Gobierno puede dársela o no darla.
Y estas visas están limitadas.
Sólo se pueden dar 65.000 al año en todo
Estados Unidos.
Y, como ya os estaréis imaginando, buena
parte de esas 65.000 visas, se dan a los trabajadores
que emigran a Silicon Valley.
Para que os hagáis una idea, sólo en el
año 2016, Google y Apple contrataron a unas
5000 personas utilizando este proceso.
Y… en fin, creo que ya podéis imaginar
lo que os voy a decir.
Esto de la visa H 1-B no le hace la más mínima
gracia a Donald Trump.
Trump ordena que sea más difícil obtener
visados H-1B
No sé si os acordáis pero hace ya dos años,
básicamente, cuando Donald Trump juró el
cargo, sacamos este vídeo donde os decíamos
todos los poderes que tiene el Presidente
de Estados Unidos.
Es decir, qué cosas puede hacer sin tener
que pasarlo por el congreso.
Pues bien, los controles de inmigración son
uno de esos poderes.
¡Pero no os equivoquéis!
Si nos vamos a los números, Obama fue tan
restrictivo con la inmigración como lo pueda
ser Trump.
La diferencia, como siempre, está en los
pequeños detalles.
Y uno de esos pequeños detalles es este visado
H 1-B.
Y se trata de algo que, en Silicon Valley,
puede suponer un auténtico problema.
Silicon Valley deja de contratar a extranjeros
para trabajos de tecnología.
Las ofertas de empleo caen en un 37% por miedo
a los controles de inmigración de Trump
Según dicen varios medios, muchas de estas
empresas tecnológicas podrían abrir nuevas
oficinas en países como Canadá, donde es
más fácil contratar inmigrantes.
Pero todavía es difícil ver lo que va a
ocurrir.
Sin embargo, la pregunta a la que sí podemos
responder ahora es ¿Y si no es Silicon Valley?
¿Cuál será la nueva capital tecnológica
del mundo?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
DE PALO ALTO A SHENZHEN
Si buscáis en Google, descubriréis que casi
cualquier ciudad del mundo quiere convertirse
en el nuevo Silicon Valley.
Basta con que un periodista encuentre a un
puñado de programadores trabajando en un
mismo espacio de coworking para que se lance
a escribir un artículo titulado “el Silicon
Valley de ´INSERTE AQUÍ NOMBRE DE CIUDAD´”
Por ejemplo, en muchos medios se cita a Berlín
como un hub de creación de startups.
Incluso el Gobierno Alemán ha abierto oficinas
en Silicon Valley para que los emprendedores
de este país puedan encontrar inversores.
Pero… lo cierto es que casi ninguna empresa
ha conseguido seducir a esos grandes fondos
de inversión californianos.
Al menos por ahora.
Así que, la pregunta es ¿Cómo sabemos si
una ciudad se está convirtiendo de verdad
en una capital tecnológica?
Pues bien, hay varias formas de medirlo.
La primera sería contar el número de unicornios
que han nacido en ese lugar.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué es un unicornio?
Pues un unicornio es una startup que llega
a valer más de 1000 millones de dólares.
En el año 2017 hubo 57 startups que se convirtieron
en unicornios.
Pues bien, de esas 57 startups, 18 no eran
de Estados Unidos sino… ¡De China!
¡Exacto!
Hablamos de empresas como DJI, que fabrican
drones o Alibaba, de la que ya hemos hablado
aquí en VisualPolitik.
Y eso explica titulares como este.
El ultimo Mercado emergente de China: el capital
riesgo
Por ejemplo, Sequoia Capital es un fondo de
capital riesgo nacido en Silicon Valley que
ya ha abierto varias oficinas en China.
¡Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando!
¿Significa esto que China va a eclipsar a
Estados Unidos?
Pues… no.
Otras ciudades como Mumbai, en la India o
Tel Aviv, en Israel también están atrayendo
muchísimo dinero de capital riesgo ¿Os suena
una empresa que se llama WIX?
Se trata de un servicio para crear páginas
web fácilmente.
Pues bien, esta empresa está fundada en Israel.
Israel apenas cuenta con unicornios, pero
supone más del 2% de todo el dinero que se
mueve en capital riesgo en el mundo.
No parece mucho pero es una auténtica barbaridad
si tenemos en cuenta que Israel entero tiene
menos población que la ciudad de Nueva York.
En resumen: que no hay ninguna alternativa
clara a Silicon Valley.
Es más, a día de hoy, incluso con la gente
que se está marchando, Silicon Valey sigue
captando más de la mitad del dinero que se
invierte en startups.
Y lo más probable es que siga manteniendo
un enorme protagonismo en este sector ¿Cuál
es la diferencia, entonces?
Bueno, pues que ahora hay más lugares donde
también se pueden sacar grandes ideas.
Dicho de otra forma, hace 30 años, si tenías
una buena idea y ganas de hacerla crecer,
prácticamente sólo había un lugar donde
podías hacerlo.
Ahora tienes más.
Y eso siempre es una buena noticia.
Así que ahora la pregunta es ¿Creéis que
Silicon Valley ha llegado a su tope y se quedará
como está, sin seguir creciendo?
¿O este éxodo será algo pasajero?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a VisualPolitik para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto!